[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And today, I'm coming to you
from the Highline in New York
City.
This is the TLDR, your update
about the coolest developer
news from Google
in the last week.
Let's start with another great
article from Daydream Labs.
Seriously, these
folks are on fire.
In this post, linked in
the description below,
the team explores how
creating 3D animation changes
when you're in VR.
TensorFlow version 0.9 is
now available with improved
mobile support, including
iOS, Raspberry Pi,
and new compilation options.
The post has links to the
release notes, mobile guide,
and samples.
We recently open sourced our
implementation of Wide and Deep
Learning as part of
the TF Learn API,
so that you can easily
train a model yourself.
Check out the post for an
explanation, tutorials,
and our research paper.
The 2016 Conference on Computer
Vision and Pattern Recognition
happened in Las Vegas last week.
And don't worry
if you missed it.
The post has links to all
the papers, talks, tutorials,
and workshops we presented.
You can now create
intelligent context-aware apps
with the Google Awareness APIs
through Google Play services.
The APIs allow your apps
to request information
about the user's
current context,
or react to changes
in the user's context,
all with minimal impact
on system resources.
If you enjoy big data and
open source, you're in luck.
In collaboration
with GitHub, we're
releasing the full snapshot
of content of more than 2.8
million open source
GitHub repositories
in Google BigQuery.
You'll have access to analyze
the source code of almost 2
billion files with a simple
or complex SQL query, which
is totally awesome.
Check out the post
to get started.
The new Google Cast SDK is
available for Android and iOS
senders.
This new SDK focuses
on making development
for Cast quicker, more reliable,
and easier to maintain.
For the intro video, doc
samples, tutorials, and more,
check out the post.
The latest version of the
Google Maps Android API is out,
and it includes several
requested features, including
the ability to order the
display of markers on the map,
the ability to set the
transparency of your tile
overlays, and a new
Circle Click listener.
The post has details and code.
AdMob Campaigns are a powerful
way to cross-promote your apps
and manage direct
sold campaigns.
With them, you
can take advantage
of innovative formats,
advanced ad serving controls,
and best in class
conversion tracking.
More info on the
post linked below.
Thanks for joining me at
the Highline this week.
Don't forget to subscribe,
because subscribing is caring.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]